[Applause]
hi i didn't know what
you were gonna come as today and my gosh
are you giving it do i look familiar
exactly the reason patrick is bringing
up the e.t thing is because
we did a little video together um and
you surprised me as
e.t yeah it was so fun i i had filmed
that youtube video
literally right away and i was like oh
my gosh can we get drew barrymore on the
phone i had been watching you on youtube
and your journey and i thought it would
just be so fun to
to kind of surprise you with this
prosthetic and then i
when you answered the phone i was like
oh my gosh this is kind of like
a weird way to kind of officially meet
the drew barrymore
uh with patrick so officially nice to
finally meet you
face to real face so it's uh
there's still uh you know a
technological
layer between us and soon hopefully
we'll be able to embrace each other in
person
but i am most certainly not um the first
person
that you can get on the line like that
when patrick starr calls we all jump can
you
talk to us about some of the people that
you've had in your youtube videos
oh my gosh of course like through
youtube i've grown
um i grew up in orlando and i've
captivated
millions of views and um on top of that
i've been able to collaborate with
celebrities like kim kardashian
and paris hilton kris jenner katy
perry to show and demystify
the celebrity beauty and what it takes
and
i think a lot of my fans have resonated
with that um because it seems so
intimidating i think
because um it seems impossible i think
and then with the power of youtube we're
able to just show and break down step by
step
how to get this ultimate celebrity
glamour so
yeah patrick i would love um if you
would
ever do my makeup when everything is
safe i would give anything to sit in
your chair
because we do learn even those of us who
are in hair and makeup chairs
throughout our lives so fortunate
there's still
never ending tips and tricks when did
you
first become interested in makeup oh my
gosh since i was a little boy i would
watch these makeup transformations i was
watching
youtube in high school and i just like
loved watching my mom too so but then i
didn't know it was allowed for boys and
then i
found what a drag queen was i found out
what stage makeup was i found
the arts in the theater and so in terms
of self-expression i thought it was
really really fun and so
i i finally picked up a brush i applied
a little bit of foundation
and foundation turned to concealer
concealer turned into lashes and then
here we are with this full cake face of
glamour
um showing millions of people that
makeup is a one size fits all
it really is and that is now the name
of your new beauty line and it
is incredible first of all i love the
packaging
as someone who has a beauty line with
flower beauty
i really love componentry it makes a
huge difference i love that you went
with this red color i think it's
disruptive
and i've never seen an aerosol
spray makeup remover um in fact i have a
video of myself
playing with all of your products and
oh yeah this is me knee deep in one size
your incredible beauty line patrick
and i have to say old school nars did
this like
lizardy yummy chartreusey green
glittery eyeliner they've since
discontinued it and this is the first
time
nobody does this color and it's one of
the most flattering to the eye color and
eye pupil
i love your range the makeup
by the way these i this liquid eyeliner
pen is my new
go-to it's incredible it's infallible it
does not
smudge or come off this line
is so impressive patrick and you also
have a new podcast tell us about that
thank you um thank you that was so cool
that you got to see all my products um
thank you so much um everything that i
do stands for love
and self-worth and value that's why my
brand is red and pink to show that
you can be loved with the power of
beauty and that is no different than on
my podcast called
say yes to the guests and why s stands
for you are successful
and hopefully with everything that i'm
doing for my messaging on my social
media from youtube
to the podcast to my beauty brand i want
everyone out there especially during
this time
in quarantine that they are loved and
they are worth it in my videos i say i
love you i support you
i believe in you i think i feel like
those words right now can resonate with
everybody all across the world and
through the power of social media
hopefully i'm able to inspire people to
be themselves and have
my guests and my peers that have made it
in their business and success through
social
media to inspire those to start their
own journey
and create a success of their own so
that's what my podcast and
everything is all about under patrick
star well since you are a
star in the beauty and makeup world it's
game show week on the show and i thought
we could play a fun game with you
are you in patrick yes let's do it
okay it's called i spy
okay so we're gonna show a close-up
picture of a celebrity's eye makeup and
if you can try and identify who that is
plus this is where i get really excited
if you can give
a tip on that eye makeup okay let's do
it all right let's put up the first
photo
oh i think i know this one i've seen her
a lot lately
this is miss let's get loud miss
jennifer lopez
oh my gosh okay
patrick looking at this eye give us one
tip to get this look liner smudging out
the liner the liner that you mentioned
which is my point made 24 hour
liquid eyeliner pen or the 24 hour gel
eyeliner just taking that all around
the eyes smudging it and blowing it out
to get that jlo fantasy
and a huge blow dryer or fan to
get the jlo wind effect and i think
you'll be set
i love that okay let's put up the second
photo
oh mama mama mama
i think i know who this one is this one
is lady gaga
okay what what household products would
we need
for this other than a blow dryer what's
a tip to
go for it as in lady gaga go for it i
think
just piling on all the makeup
and a tip i think for people out there
is to take a mirror and take a step
back and see your makeup from far away
because sometimes when we're doing our
makeup we're like so
up close that we don't really get to see
the effect um
of what it really is and i feel like
you're able to take a step back and
really
envision the entire look and just have
confidence and i think that's what lady
gaga is all about
oh gosh patrick that's such a smart
astute comment
take a look from far away because we do
we have our nose in it and we can't see
any perspective brilliant tip okay last
photo patrick
can you guess who this is oh my gosh
i think that's my sephora sister miss
rihanna of fenty beauty
oh gosh patrick you're so good at this
okay any tip for getting the re-re
look oh my gosh for a look like this
taking eye shadow and incorporating it
as blush
um throughout the the tones of your face
i think is really nice
um as you see that there's a little bit
of magenta in her p
in her lip in her cheeks in her eyes and
i'm
all about a monochrome look head to toe
turban to toes so
if you can rock this monochrome theme i
think it'll be really really flattering
on anyone no matter what tone you are
i love the monochromatic tip and
sometimes i'll take the lipstick i'm
wearing and dot it on my cheeks
just to make a blush and keep that color
consistent
patrick all of your tips are just so
amazing you're so amazing you're such an
authority
and we love and hang on your every word
i
cannot thank you enough for coming on
the show this has been one of my
favorite segments
be sure to check out patrick's
extraordinary beauty line one size and
his podca
podcast say yes to the guest